After all these talking about requirements, let's have a small quiz, I
want to ask you which of the
following requirements are non-functional requirements? And here
I'm listing the requirements, the first one says at the BowlingAlley program
keeps track of the score during a game, the second one is that
the WordCount program should be able to process large files. The third
one is that the Login program for a website. Should be secure, and
finally the last one says that the vending machine program should take coins
as an input from the user. So, I want you to mark all
the ones that are non-functional requirements, that
don't refer to the functionality of the system.